Apple has now secretly started
production of the iPhone 15 lineup in
India for the first time which gives us
a major hint that the rumors of a
September 12th event date are true but
the main thing I want to discuss in this
video is a major leak that has to do
with the switch to USBC and it being
better than anyone is expecting yes I'm
talking about brand new leaks that all
but confirmed the existence of
Thunderbolt and usb4 support on the new
iPhone 15 Pro Models as well as
confirmation of our biggest fear for the
regular iPhone 15 models mfi
restrictions on USBC so in this video
I'm going to explain how we know apple
is working on this why Apple would
introduce Thunderbolt support in the
first place and what it's ultimately
going to mean for you so let's get
started for many months now there have
been countless leaks and rumors from
various reliable sources that have
confirmed that the upcoming iPhone 15
light up next month is teaching
lightning for USBC this includes
multiple leaked CAD files which lead to
renders and even dummy models all
showing off the new USBC Port including
this one that just popped up from
Imagine boot on Twitter and this one is
by far the most realistic and accurate
model that I've seen yet showing off the
redesigned curved edges that blend into
the display looking super comfortable to
hold in your hands as well as this back
angle including a very familiar camera
bump and the new action button that'll
be replacing the mute switch but now
getting into Thunderbolt and how we know
apple is working on it a Twitter user
named John leaked the USBC connector
Parts showing the actual ports with flex
cables and the most interesting detail
is that Apple color match the insides of
each port to the actual iPhone's finish
he then went on to share more photos of
the actual Flex cables with more details
and another Twitter user kasutami-san
showed off an even higher quality image
with more very interesting details and
somehow Jon even got access to a video
clip of a USBC cable being plugged into
one of these Flex cable components now I
know you're probably wondering if these
USBC components with flex cables are
even Apple parts to begin with what if
they're from some other random phone
instead well Majin Buu got rid of all
doubt when he posted these photos of the
iPhone 15 plus usb-c Flex cable actually
showing some labels with the Apple logo
on them and taking it a step further he
showed a close-up chip with the code
3ld3 which is apparently an apple design
chip which might be there for
transmission encryption with one
commenter claiming that we have the same
chip inside of Apple's USBC cable so it
must take two of them to authentic okay
this means that Apple might be forcing
users to use official mfi Apple USBC
cables if they want to unlock the
fastest transfer speeds which would
basically go against EU law limiting
third-party cables from working at the
fastest speeds however Apple could allow
the fast speeds in the EU only and
restrict the rest of the world like us
and then other than that this could just
be a chip that protects your iPhone from
being hacked or having data stolen and
if it does limit speeds I think it could
be in a totally different way and that
way could specifically be four
Thunderbolt support so let's move on to
the evidence for that a company named
charger lab is claiming that they've
seen additional photos of the iPhone 15
Flex cable leaks and they now believe
that some of them show an integrated
circuit for Thunderbolt data transfer
speeds apparently the IC retimer rebuild
signals and mitigates Jitter which helps
stabilize high capacity data ports and
extends transmission ranges something
that is often seen on Thunderbolt
devices and charger lab believes that
they see those chips on the iPhone 15
USBC components now all of this might be
very hard to believe but it's actually
not the first time we've heard about
Thunderbolt coming to the iPhone 15 Pro
Models way back in April we had a huge
leak thread that came from analyst 941 a
Twitter account who claimed that his
sister worked at Apple and gave him info
that he secretly leaked behind her back
on Twitter and long story short she
allegedly got caught and fired so he
disappeared as well but back in April he
leaked at the iPhone 15 Pro Models would
get Thunderbolt 3 saying that apple is
heavily invested into video recording
for this year with a focus on importing
video to two workstation Max which
explains the Thunderbolt support and if
you didn't already know Apple's current
iPhone 14 lineup is limited to transfer
speeds of only 480
gigabits per second while Thunderbolt 3
and 4 can do 40
000 which is literally 80 times faster
even further analyst 941 claimed that
there will be special Thunderbolt 4
features in iOS 17 that would be hidden
until the launch of the iPhone 15 Pro
because it's reserved for those models
so right now we only have to wait a
couple of more weeks to find out if he
was telling the truth or not now one of
those features would be a new
cinematography feature that'll allow
live 4K Thunderbolt outputs to monitors
while recording which sounds like
something Apple would do and can easily
be achievable with Thunderbolt support
and just in case you didn't think
analyst 941 was reliable enough we also
had Ming choco who predicted back in
November of last year that the iPhone 15
Pro Models would support at least USB
3.2 or Thunderbolt 3 while the regular
15 models would be stuck with USB 2.0
speeds which of course sucks now with
all that evidence out of the way let me
get into the question of why Apple would
introduce Thunderbolt in the first place
well for one we know that Apple's
iPhones have had a bad reputation for
super slow transfer speeds so if Apple
makes a massive jump up to Thunderbolt
they would instantly knock out the
competition since the iPhone would
essentially be the first mainstream
phone with Thunderbolt support now being
much faster than the rest of the
smartphone competition going further it
would help Apple package the 15 Pro as a
real cinematographer's device with a
full Suite of video production features
especially Apple pushing for prores
video and hopefully 8K video recording
coming soon the addition of Thunderbolt
could help some users justify buying the
new 2 terabyte storage model which is
rumored to be coming to the 15 Pros next
month on top of that Thunderbolt support
would be another big feature to help
upsell more Pro Models just like how
Apple added Thunderbolt to the iPad Pro
to help slow more of those and
differentiate them from the regular
iPads and finally let's finish off with
what Thunderbolt support means for you
well first of all it would mean insanely
fast iPhone data backups to your Mac as
well as restoring your data as well now
part of the reason people don't want to
do this right now is because it simply
takes forever with the slow 480 megabits
per second transfer speeds but using
Thunderbolt would make the process
literally only take a few minutes
depending on the amount of storage on
your iPhone also we've seen many
complaints of users shooting prores
video which takes up a huge amount of
storage and also taking forever to get
them transferred to your Mac because
airdrop is slow and unreliable for
massive transfers like that so
Thunderbolt would be the perfect
solution for transferring large video
files so with all that said I'm
extremely excited for USBC and
Thunderbolt to finally replace the slow
lightning ports we currently have and if
you enjoyed this video subscribe above
and check out one of those two videos
right over there thanks for watching and
we'll see you in the next one
foreign